the shea family tonight and it reads in  part  the shea family is deeply grateful for  the outpouring of love  and respect shown in the wake of tony's  passing  family that he had a profound impact on  countless people  all over the world tony was extremely  accomplished in both his personal  and professional lives most proud of how  he turned out as a human being  the shea family hopes to carry on tony's  legacy by spreading the tenants he lived  by  finding joy through meaningful life  experience inspiring and helping others  and most of all  delivering happiness you can read that  full statement on our website at eight  newsnow dot com